welcome to this video pinned your Latos
pin you laters yeah well we gotta be
known in yeah kind of Shaq benoni but I
have not played c4 and it's usually
considered to be an advantage to not
have played this the question is should
I play a form this is a possible
possible line hmm so also Bishop b5
sometimes this is an idea okay let's
just develop cannot be bad really you
might play Bishop g5 and prepare Bishop
g5 not much I can do about that I still
have the space advantage though it's
quite quite a convenient position for
white to play still I need to to find a
plan what's a good plan here hmm I'd
like to fix the queenside maybe try to
reroute the night to see form the zone
would be nice okay I'll try to try to do
that quickly nighty 32 c for only 30 wow
that's a drastic measure hmm okay
now he might he might intend to lie to
to default but he's weakened the light
squares considerably if I go Bishop g4
now now 94 c 3 9 p-3 it's quite
embarrassing this I really should avoid
I wonder ever should play C 3 i'm abc3
to cover deform and now this this
morning my bishop is not so great i
really wouldn't mind to exchange it yeah
the night is only three just where it
belongs we can you can try to play on
them on the King side of course but not
sure how dangerous it really is I need
to coordinate the orbit the Sun Queen on
c1 is not really well placed maybe g3
cringy form i need to getting the Queen
soft would be okay also treating all the
way okay let's
but surprising okay let's put it on so
far as it was planned the whole time
slight issue of course is this pressure
on their farm the bit a bit of a problem
yeah maybe f3 a cesium tomb to protect
mmm no no I'm unsure black seems to be
ok here with f5 f5 was I know probably i
didn't i didn't play it well I don't
really believe that it is good but damn
I didn't refute it at all Black is
completely ok here this is a bit a bit
passive 7 you're really playing e4 now
this this only helps wide I think rookie
for this rook f6 rook f6 and then you
can take on c4 or what hmm now let's
it's it's good for white rook e6 with
lukey a to this kind of move the rook
does not have many squares
now let's say rookie edit screen a5
coming and now it hangs and rook e8 made
I played very quickly stuff like before
you really you really need to consider
if he doesn't do that like it's okay I
don't think he's got any problems and
you are not sure maybe ninety one is
really slim snow move black resigned
yeah yeah it's just it's just gone maybe
you can take with the night but that's
also not it didn't help them I mean why
opened up lines it's mostly good for me
a simple continuation but not bad is
really one just am getting this
exchanged check and now some active move
Queen a five or something I mean I still
have the snide being more active or move
like that I mean this is just a bit bit
better for white it's probably
defensible but not it's not very
comfortable if black does not do that
this you form business and just stay put
on the FR don't think I don't have
anything you could try to get this
exchanged maybe on c5 I don't see how
them you can just stay put i don't
really have a good plan I mean what can
I do a a form at some point but hard to
prepare yeah black it's just okay with
efore it was this was a bit of self
destruction on black spot alright thanks
for watching